Despekiring Abukuma Una weblog Rose Splash en
Pad audi new open
car for Star 2 mr are
you
do Disc Closer League Loss
Grape Bestone
stars in Ginza
neverend on loan So
Fashion
Home Pro Stream s Kumanosha is closed
.
I'm the president of a kimono shop in Ginza, Tokyo
It's made in the place where it's sweetened
. Oshima Tsumugi is said to be the finest kimono in that kimono,
isn't it?
Sometimes it's an email, but it's not a group. It seems like a flower that
such a small Kasuko wants to do
so far. Do you think this is Japanese aesthetics
?
[Music]
ender ender
4 s tenoras to
[Music]
do 4 Barcorn
Go Kanai
Oshima Tsumugi is dyed with mud. Oshima
Tsumugi is described as a kimono with a history of at least 1300 years
.
When
the three people chemically react with the iron content of the muddy field, the
red is clarified 10 to 30 times per black, and
it is fitted with an adroda.
I think that's what remains in the color.
[Music]
Sansei r japanese to
do sc Eatable Astimara
with the finest 2nd and 3rd generation
Kimono that you have, or you're
returning home in the mud.  When the kimono is
finished and washed
cleanly, it will be
really beautiful. I think that it is now the greatest weapon of self-expression,
especially this time Oshima.  Sin
Japan's best thing The world I'm most proud of when I wear it
[Music]
[Applause]